there is a change machine ATM and when I
over here I noticed that there's a
little bit of glue and just because I'm
paranoid with cyber security iide just
to go ahead and give us a tug and I'll
let you hear so it actually comes right
off this is very well made you can see
it's an exact replica it's a real
Hacker's device and it's called a
skimmer frauders put skimmers on the ATM
card reader or inconspicuously Mount
them on the hull the skimmer is a simple
device a magnetic strip card reader the
board was stolen data is stored and the
battery to steal the PIN codes
fraudsters use pinhole cameras to be
safe you can cover the keypad when
typing a pin code but that won't save
you if the fraud has used an overhead
keyboard that collects PIN codes the
crooks must use all their creative
talents to make the skimmers invisible
skimmers are very difficult to recognize
but if you see a lot of glue find
another
ATM